so we have an example exercise from our
Khan Academy exercises this is the
decomposed fractions with denominators
of 100 so use a following number line to
complete the equation the equation says
26 hundredths is equal to star tenths
plus 6 hundredths and they give us this
number line and on this number line
let's see this is 0 right over here 0
tenths which is the same thing as 0 and
it goes all the way to 26 hundredths
let's see if that makes sense well you
see between zero tenths and 1/10 they
split into 10 equal sections 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 so if you divide a 10th into
tenths each of these is going to be a
hundred a hundredth is one tenth of a
tenth so it's one hundred two hundred
three hundred four hundred five six
seven eight nine ten hundredths 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 19 20 hundredths 21 22 23
24 25 26 hundredths so that's exactly
what they wrote there so they say 26
hundreds which is this thing right over
here is equal to star tenths which is
really what's being depicted in magenta
plus six hundredths the six hundredths
is this green right over you're adding
the 600's adding one two three four five
six hundredths so what is what is this
right over here this this this magenta
or this pink arrow well we could say
that's 20 hundredths if you count it
that's 10 20 hundredths or you can see
well that's just two tenths so 26
hundredths is the same thing as two
tenths plus six hundredths and it gets
you right over there so this right over
here is going to be two tenths